măsurarea unei superpozitii cuantice este la fel de aleatorie ca aruncarea unei monede, dar cât de departe putem duce această
analogie înainte să se destrame? vom afla azi la kiss in the
classroom bine ai venit la kiss in the classroom, o serie de videoclipuri în care descompunem un concept fundamental pe care l-ai putea
întâlni într-un curs legat de Quantum Computing fiecare videoclip este însoțit de un modul interactiv inclus în
descrierea de mai jos, deci asigură-te că îl consulți azi vorbim despre unul dintre principiile de bază din inima
teoriei cuantice: superpozitia în experiența noastră de zi cu zi, obiectele au mereu caracteristici definite — locația, dimensiunea,
forma, culoarea — totul despre ele este determinat și cert, chiar dacă noi, observatorii, nu l-am măsurat încă în
lumea cuantică asta nu este neapărat cazul un obiect cuantic poate fi în ceva numit superpozitie de
multiple stări clasic permise, care, atunci când este măsurat, va collapsa aleatoriu la una dintre acele
stări măsurarea unei stări de superpozitie este ca aruncarea unei monede — nu există nicio modalitate de a ști dinainte în ce parte va
cădea acest indeterminism fundamental este un aspect incomod al mecanicii cuantice cu care chiar și Einstein a avut probleme
el a spus faimoasa frază „Dumnezeu nu joacă zaruri" despre această aleatorie, dar, după cum vom vedea, Dumnezeu chiar joacă zaruri sau, în
cazul nostru, aruncă monede dar mai mult decât atât, aceste monede sunt trucate — măsurarea unei superpozitii cuantice poate fi similară cu
aruncarea unei monede în unele privințe, dar superpozitia în sine este mult mai bogată și mai complexă decât o stare
probabilistică clasică pentru a vedea asta, ne vom gândi la cum funcționează o monedă clasică și vom face o comparație cu
moneda noastră cuantică, pe care o vom explora folosind un qubit pe un calculator cuantic IBM mai întâi, o monedă clasică — este
destul de simplă: arunci moneda și aceasta aterizează fie cu capul în sus, fie cu capul în jos, cu o șansă de 50% pentru fiecare ei bine, în principiu am putea
calcula pe ce parte va ateriza moneda dacă am ști condițiile inițiale precise ale monedei și exact
câtă forță și cuplu au fost aplicate în timpul aruncării, dar în practică nu există nicio modalitate de a ști a priori pe ce parte va
ateriza moneda de aceea folosim aruncarea monedei ca exemplu canonic al unei stări probabilistice clasice, unde
rezultatul este în esență aleatoriu dacă aș arunca această monedă de o mie de ori și aș înregistra numărul de capete în sus
și capete în jos, aș obține o histogramă care arată cam așa deci avem numărătoarea pe axa Y
și poate fi fie capete în sus, fie capete în jos, iar
histograma ar arăta că există aproximativ 500 de numărători pentru fiecare, cu o anumită
fluctuație statistică putem crea o stare similară folosind un qubit pe calculatorul nostru cuantic — ca aruncarea monedei,
un qubit poate fi de asemenea măsurat în două stări posibile: zero și unu dacă aplicăm ceva numit un Hadamard gate unui
qubit, îl va pune într-o superpozitie egală de zero și unu iată o
vizualizare a acelui circuit pe care l-am numit diagramă de circuit — aici firul de sus este
qubit-ul, iar operațiile aplicate qubit-ului apar ca casete pe fire — Hadamard gate este afișat cu această casetă
etichetată H, iar măsurarea este afișată cu această casetă gri etichetată cu micul simbol de măsurare — aceasta trimite
măsurarea la un bit clasic, acest fir cu două linii deci, deoarece qubit-ul este în o superpozitie egală de 0 și unu, când
îl măsurăm, va exista o șansă de 50% să măsurăm zero și 50% să măsurăm
unu exprimăm această stare de superpozitie cuantică ca s = 1 / <
tk2 0 + 1 / < tk2 1 unde pătratele fiecăruia dintre acești
coeficienți, numiți și amplitudini, sunt probabilitățile de a măsura fiecare stare deci, în esență, aplicarea Hadamard
gate este echivalentul aruncării unei monede și, la fel cum am aruncat moneda de o mie de ori pentru a analiza
statisticile monedei care aterizează cu capul în sus sau în jos, putem face ceva similar pe Qiskit cu moneda noastră cuantică
vom folosi o primitivă Qiskit numită sampler, care va repeta circuit-ul de mai multe ori pentru a eșantiona statisticile
stării rezultante cu o mie de eșantioane din circuit-ul de mai sus, avem ceva care arată practic identic
cu histograma monedei clasice, până la o anumită fluctuație statistică deci atât este? superpozițiile
cuantice sunt în esență aceleași cu o stare probabilistică clasică, analog cu aruncarea unei monede? nu chiar — acesta ar fi
un videoclip destul de scurt dacă ar fi cazul pentru a vedea prima noastră diferență cheie, voi încerca ceva ușor diferit cu moneda mea clasică — în loc
să o las pur și simplu să cadă pe masă, aterizând fie cu capul în sus, fie în jos, voi arunca moneda și o voi prinde
în aer între palmele mele acum moneda nu are capul în sus sau în jos, ci în schimb are capul fie la stânga,
fie la dreapta deci logica ne spune că și aceasta ar trebui să aibă o probabilitate 50/50 de a fi
fie capul la stânga, fie la dreapta pentru a măsura capul la stânga sau la dreapta pe moneda noastră cuantică, putem face ceea ce am făcut cu moneda clasică —
să măsurăm de-a lungul unei axe diferite măsurătorile noastre standard pe calculatorul cuantic sunt de-a lungul axei verticale,
la fel ca măsurarea obișnuită a monedei clasice cu capul în sus sau în jos, dar putem, de asemenea, întreba moneda noastră cuantică dacă are
capul la stânga sau la dreapta — numim aceste două stări de-a lungul axei x plus sau minus
pentru aceasta folosim primitiva Qiskit numită estimator pentru a complica puțin lucrurile — în loc să returneze o histogramă, ca
sampler, estimator ne va da în schimb așa-numita valoare de așteptare a oricărui observabil al qubit-ului pentru a
înțelege această valoare de așteptare, să spunem că primești un dolar de fiecare dată când moneda aterizează cu capul în sus și pierzi un dolar când
aterizează cu capul în jos — valoarea de așteptare este câți bani te poți aștepta să câștigi în medie cu fiecare aruncare a monedei deoarece
este la fel de probabil să câștigi sau să pierzi un dolar, valoarea de așteptare ar fi zero același raționament poate fi aplicat
qubit-ului când găsim valoarea de așteptare a lui x — când aplicăm x la starea plus, obținem
valoarea + unu și la starea minus obținem minus unu deci dacă am avea o
distribuție 50/50, am obține o valoare de așteptare de zero, dar nu obținem — obținem o valoare de așteptare de plus unu,
ceea ce înseamnă că moneda este mereu măsurată ca plus de-a lungul axei x asta ar fi ca și cum ai arunca o
monedă, ai prinde-o și ai garanta că capul ar fi mereu orientat spre dreapta asta se datorează faptului că o
superpozitie nu este doar o distribuție de probabilitate ține minte cum exprimăm o stare cuantică
s egală cu C 0 * starea 0 plus C1
WEBVTT
* starea 1, unde fiecare dintre acești coeficienți este complex, adică
au atât părți reale cât și imaginare, deci ne spun despre probabilități, dar ascund și o altă cantitate numită
faza un coeficient C poate fi scris astfel:
C egal cu magnitudine înmulțită cu această fază, unde fi este
faza este un pic ca faza unui val sau locația crestelor și jgheaburilor unui val — dacă două valuri sunt în fază
una cu cealaltă, astfel încât crestele și jgheaburile lor se aliniază, ele se vor combina pentru a forma un val de două ori mai
înalt — numim asta interferență constructivă dacă sunt defazate ca
aceasta, ele interferează distructiv, anulându-se complet pentru a vedea cum faza poate cauza
interferență în moneda noastră cuantică, să încercăm să aplicăm Hadamard de două ori în loc de o singură dată — acum, clasic,
asta nu ar avea niciun sens — dacă aplicarea Hadamard este echivalentă cu aruncarea unei monede, atunci nu poți arunca o monedă care se aruncă deja — dar să vedem ce
se întâmplă mecanic cuantic deci aplicăm Hadamard de două ori și eșantionăm starea rezultantă
uimitor, nu mai avem o probabilitate 50/50 — histograma rezultantă arată că în fiecare caz măsurăm
qubit-ul în starea zero, deci al doilea Hadamard a readus qubit-ul la starea zero de unde am pornit — este
puțin dificil de văzut la prima vedere, dar asta se datorează interferenței stării cuantice — dar în loc să
interfereze în spațiul real ca un val actual, interferența se întâmplă în spațiul abstract al informației qubit-ului
al doilea Hadamard gate a cauzat ca partea Zero a superpozitiei să interfereze constructiv, în timp ce partea unu a
superpozitiei a interferat distructiv și a dispărut — să explorăm mai departe — putem schimba faza folosind
ceva numit un phase gate — deci acum să aplicăm un Hadamard pentru a crea superpozitia, să aplicăm un defazaj de
pi radiani și apoi să aplicăm al doilea Hadamard — acum se pare că moneda noastră cuantică iese mereu în starea unu
defazajul de pi a schimbat între ele părțile stării de superpozitie care erau în fază și defazate una față de cealaltă,
deci starea finală este unu în loc de zero — asta ar fi ca și cum ai arunca o monedă și, cât timp este în aer, ai putea
cumva aplica o operație care ar garanta că aterizează mereu cu capul în sus sau mereu cu capul în jos, în funcție de
operație — imposibil în cazul clasic, dar nu și în cazul cuantic — ceea ce am învățat din aceste experimente este
că această nouă capacitate a monedei cuantice se datorează fazei sale — o calitate pe care o are o superpozitie cuantică, dar pe care
o distribuție de probabilitate clasică nu o are — deci aruncarea obișnuită a monedei nu este de fapt o analogie foarte bună pentru o
superpozitie deoarece nu spune nimic despre această fază — cred că putem face mai bine — voi face un alt
experiment cu moneda noastră — am moneda așezată pe masă cu capul în sus — pentru a o pune cu capul în jos, pot pur și simplu să o întorc — acesta este
echivalentul computational al unui not gate — să zicem că vrem să construim o operație care, dacă ar fi aplicată de două ori, ar fi
echivalentă cu acest not gate — putem numi această operație o rădăcină pătrată a lui not — deci gândește-te la ce facem fizic
când aplicăm not gate — o rotim 180° — de exemplu, în jurul axei x — deci dacă am roti moneda
doar 90° în jurul axei x, asta ne-ar da rădăcina pătrată a lui not — deci am aplicat
rădăcina noastră pătrată a lui not și moneda stă pur și simplu pe muchie — acum putem întreba: are capul în sus sau în jos? ei bine,
clar nu este niciunul, dar am putea adăuga un pas procesului de măsurare pentru a o forța să fie cu capul în sus sau în jos — acum
moneda va cădea fie cu capul în sus, fie cu capul în jos, cu probabilitate egală — din nou, în principiu am putea prezice
în ce parte va cădea, dar în practică este suficient de greu de prezis pentru a-l face practic aleatoriu — dacă vreau să
măsor dacă are capul la stânga sau la dreapta, o pot zdrobi în acea direcție într-un mod similar și ne va da din nou o
probabilitate 50/50 de stânga și dreapta, dar în această dimensiune, capul față sau spate,
capul este deja orientat înainte, deci 100% din timp o vom măsura cu capul înainte — deci, deși măsurătorile x și z
au dat rezultate aleatoare, măsurătoarea Y va da mereu același rezultat — dacă ne gândim înapoi la
experimentul cu aruncarea monedei cuantice din secțiunea anterioară, asta amintește de cum s-a comportat moneda cuantică după
aplicarea Hadamard — qubit-ul a fost măsurat fie în zero, fie în 1 cu probabilitate 50/50 în direcția Z, dar
mereu starea plus și niciodată starea minus de-a lungul lui X — asta sugerează că poate o monedă stând nemișcată pe
muchie este o modalitate mai bună de a vizualiza o stare de superpozitie a unui qubit decât o monedă care se rotește haotic în aer
să aplicăm un gate rădăcina pătrată a lui not pe moneda noastră cuantică în Qiskit — avem acest circuit simplu
apoi vom folosi estimator pentru a verifica valoarea de așteptare a celor trei observabile X Y și Z, care sunt un pic ca
prăbușirea monedei noastre de-a lungul fiecăruia dintre cele trei dimensiuni, cum tocmai am arătat — deci valorile de așteptare sunt 0,
minus unu și 0 pentru X, Y și Z respectiv — acesta este același rezultat pe care l-am
obținut pentru rotația rădăcina pătrată a lui not aplicată monedei clasice — de fapt, există o analogie precisă între
monedă și starea qubit-ului — acum putem vizualiza starea qubit-ului ca un vector care indică în direcția capului
pe monedă, normal la suprafața monedei — deci capul în sus sau starea zero
pe moneda cuantică este echivalent cu un vector care indică drept în sus — capul în jos sau unu indică drept în jos și orice
superpozitie egală de 0 și unu indică orizontal — faza stării cuantice determină direcția orizontală exactă
în care indică — de exemplu, dacă indică de-a lungul axei x sau de-a lungul axei Y sau undeva la
mijloc — acest vector este cunoscut ca vectorul Bloch și determină complet și unic starea cuantică a unui singur
qubit — acum putem reimagina fiecare gate pe care l-am văzut în acest videoclip ca o rotație sau o serie de rotații pe
monedă sau echivalent pe vectorul Bloch — not gate este o rotație de
180° în jurul axei x — aplicat la starea noastră zero sau capul în sus, se întoarce la starea
în jos sau unu — rădăcina pătrată a lui not este doar 90° în jurul aceleiași axe x — pornind
de la starea capului în sus, asta îl rotește la capul înainte — un phase gate este o rotație de fi în jurul axei Z — deoarece
capul în sus este aliniat cu axa Z, asta nu face nimic monedei — Hadamard gate este puțin mai complicat —
inițial l-am asemănat cu aruncarea unei monede, făcând moneda să se rotească necontrolat în aer, dar Hadamard este de fapt o
WEBVTT
rotație controlată, deterministă a monedei — ca toate celelalte gate-uri, Hadamard este realizat prin rotire cu 90°
în jurul axei Y și apoi 180° în jurul axei x — deci aplicat la starea cu capul în sus, ajunge
să fie cu capul la dreapta — deci nu există nimic aleatoriu în legătură cu o stare de superpozitie cuantică sau cu oricare dintre
operațiile standard pe care le efectuăm pe qubit — fiecare operație este deterministă și reversibilă — singurul
moment în care aleatorul intră în joc este când decidem să măsurăm starea cuantică — dacă o stare cuantică este chiar în
superpozitie depinde cu adevărat de perspectiva observatorului — după cum ai întâlnit probabil, suntem liberi să alegem
sistemul nostru de coordonate — X, Y și Z pot indica în oricare trei direcții ortogonale — deci
dacă avem o superpozitie de 0 și unu într-un sistem de coordonate, putem defini un nou sistem de coordonate sau o nouă
bază, în care starea indică pur în direcția plus Z și, prin urmare, nu se află în o stare de superpozitie
deci când spunem că un qubit este în superpozitie, trebuie să definim și sistemul nostru de coordonate sau
baza e posibil să închei acest modul cu impresia că tocmai am eliminat tot misterul din mecanica cuantică
la urma urmei, unul dintre aspectele presupus cele mai ciudate — starea de superpozitie a unui qubit — este de fapt la fel de simplu ca un
vector tridimensional dar ține minte că moneda este totuși doar o analogie și chiar și vectorul Bloch este
doar un instrument de vizualizare — pentru a calcula probabilitățile rezultatelor măsurătorilor, nu putem spune ce face o stare cuantică
cu adevărat înainte de a fi măsurată, deoarece verificarea asta necesită o măsurătoare — vom discuta această
dilemă despre care este adevărata natură a unei stări cuantice și cum fenomenul cuantic al entanglementului ne poate ajuta să
elucidăm asta într-un alt episod de Qiskit in the classroom, dedicat inegalității lui Bell — între timp, dacă
vrei să te joci cu monede cuantice pentru a învăța singur despre stările de superpozitie ale unui qubit și cum să le controlezi,
accesează modulul quantum coins inclus în descriere — mulțumesc că ai vizionat și ne vedem data viitoare